hello everyone so if you haven't noticed
we're in Washington DC and we're about
to head into the White House for a
fun-filled day of things I'm joined with
Jenna and Jay hello it's a long time
2011 you Sunday maybe ever even have
cameras Becca but now we're here at the
White House I mean we talked on Twitter
all the times looks like I felt like is
are you where we stay close
gosh I'm feeling so presidential today
looking very presidential
for so presidential presidential excited
we're gonna record it we're now going to
the East Wing and I don't know what else
is going to happen so I'll tell you what
happens when we get there
Ford's here come on
Oh presidential it's snowing sweep we
weren't in the way now oh okay
I'm I'm lost I need a map it's been
confirmed that this is officially the
White House look at everybody's logging
and snapping you think it's not yeah
it's like the pictures why not to take
pictures in video and come away but I'm
not sure when that ended they never went
looking because I keep filming so we're
just gonna I guess I'm here over here
we're on our way East Wing I think we're
here oh whatever
okay I'm on super confused
Subic residential we don't know what's
going on at all it's nobody knows it's
going good are you okay Norbert not yet
no I just go back into town but soon we
have to make it happen Jenny and God
have a northern
Maddie will have a field day so we're
here at the White House are you excited
I'm sorry I want to say I said this is
Obama or cost we don't see Obama out
he's got to be here it's got to be here
we're heading to the garden and it's
snowing it's officially snowing it's so
cold but yet the snow is to hold
presidential person you ever seen there
it is every white highlight Channel
we are gonna have so many of the same
vlogs there's gonna be like 70 can we
get closer to just run on the lawn
anyway at least I tried so hard to
picture we're try it's a rumor we're not
going to beat Obama but this was like
basically the second best so here is the
presidential gardens it's looking a
little bit covered up for winter we
gotta protect the crops guys uh I guess
I'll walk through the garden hi welcome
to the garden er sleeve peppers cabbages
celery oh we're at the White House wait
not yet okay dad Nevis I should be are
you Barry do you lie electrocuted that
was so joy I actually Jake it looks cute
it great for real my god yeah I did get
buried
cuz I was helping oh yeah this is yeah I
don't want to see okay
oh gosh look at her it's winter guys
that you can't have a garden on the East
Coast in the winter well what do you
think of its are you know I think it's
cold but it's noise but it's snowing I
think then despite the snow and the cold
that surrounds that this garden
continues to prevail I mean I'm
surprised anything's growing without
freaking cold it in
so this is still this is progress this
means we have hope for the future
everybody oh gosh okay I got infected I
think we got a picture I'm not sure if
any of them came out but we tried our
best so that is the closest that we're
gonna get to the action with white house
now I'm not sure what we're going
surprise surprise there's a lot of
people here it's like a youtuber meetup
it's like a small little VidCon in size
he decides
and then a champion for this cause and
for women the Vice President of the
United States Joe Biden we just saw Joe
Biden and this is the most incredible
passionate speech that I've ever seen it
was so great I wish I could filmed it
all for you guys but it was it would
have been a little long I was enjoying
it on my personal matters we're now
heading up to the third floor I can't
tell you what's going on next was I
don't know your hands we are now in
another room there's chairs there's
paper
there's thankfully a snack because I'm
very hungry I should have brought a
treat I did not he also got coffee we're
about to do some things I don't know
John I'm setting a life I wish that I
had more information but I don't but I'm
going to eat this presidential candy
we're all issues that we all care about
here at the White House they're all
issues in our office White House Office
of Public Engagement the opposite deals
with less officials around the country
of course Valerie Jarrett
we are at our final one house
destination we're getting some food
you haven't met Obama yet I don't think
I don't think we're going to get to
today he might be here though might be
here is going to live right that's where
we are we're going to dinner
oh yeah I didn't even get an Elfa cat
photo even like make it look like I got
a photo with the Pres
oh yeah but I got a picture from this
tiny door so it's great it's my shot
we're gonna go to dinner wine in the
elevator
wait I don't think that goes in wait
this is exit we can't figure out how to
get out of here that could be a small
problem this is the official exiting of
not the White House
the Eisenhower building I wish I could
even tell you all the things that we did
today but it was a lot of things a lot
of running around
we don't get to see much of the White
House so because it's currently in a
transition period everyone's basically
packing their bags preparing to leave
it's very sad sad feeling here can't
really explain it probably don't need to
explain it
that's a big shatter it something like
no no I thought yeah I can I can't use
my phone well I just wanted to say hi
and bye and what's that what's that your
you want it really quick real quick you
guys my puzzle came in the mail when
you're looking at Matt just look at what
I got new ones and Matt's over there
like creep it like